et les stigmates d'une guerre qui se
poursuit des maisons noircies encore
fumantes et dans les jardins des tombes
dimanche des bombardements russes ont
tués de sexagénaires la mer et le
beau-père de Maxime sa voisine est
encore sous le choc
nous sommes des simples civils nous
n'avons personne ici nous avons donné
nous n'avons pas de soldats pourquoi
nous bombarde-t-il
[Musique]
nos pose cette question pourquoi vous
restez mais où sommes-nous censés aller
c'est notre terre nous avons grandi si
nous vivons ici
Shanks qui est une ville stratégique sur
la route de la grande ville régionale
kramatork elle est pilonnée depuis des
semaines les habitants manquent de tout
plus d'accès ni à l'eau potable ni à
l'électricité
ma famille ma femme et mes deux enfants
sont partis il me manque beaucoup ils
sont inquiets il n'y a pas de réseau et
je ne peux pas leur dire que je suis en
vie et que je vais bien
une ville devenue déserte les
bombardements pleuvent sans discontinuer
selon la police de la région de louansk
chaque jour les bombardements
s'intensifient sur les routes on voit
les poteaux électriques et les câbles
couchés c'est très difficile de conduire
nous n'avons qu'une seule voiture et
nous n'avons nulle part où aller pour
changer les roues
plusieurs jours l'artillerie ukrainienne
s'est installé à lucide pour viser
l'armée russe assez vérodoniettes de
l'autre côté de la rivière